president biden and ungrateful hollywood
liberals bashing america on the fourth
of july lashing out over the recent
supreme court ruling on abortion
liberty is under salt
assault both here and abroad
in recent days
there's been reason to think that this
country is moving backward
that freedom is being reduced
that rights
we assume were protected are no longer
hollywood celebs following biden's lead
barbra streisand claims our democratic
republic remains in danger because of
former president trump
jessica chastain using july 4 to flash
her middle fingers classy and katy perry
getting mocked after tweeting quote baby
you're a firework is a ten but women in
the u.s have fewer rights than an actual
sparkler
okay
harold you know if these people are so
unhappy here
why are they here
well i don't want to speak for for them
i imagine if they wonder well they're
speaking to you
most of them are wealthy enough they
could do whatever they want but i tell
you i step back and look i i don't
express myself that way i think
yesterday jesse and i think i texted
about everybody around the table uh with
the exception of kayla saying look this
is the day to pause and celebrate
uh the brilliance and courage of our
founders we should all recognize that
they were brilliant they were not
perfect
and when we accept that we realize that
the challenge they gave us is to make
them make the union more perfect so as i
listened to them you know i probably
would again i wouldn't have done it
quite that way but you think about the
backdrop 25 of america proves of the
supreme court judge you know that really
means that's a moniker and kayla you
know as well that's a moniker for the
rule of law and when the country does
not respect the final arbiter of that at
the level it should that number has
never been that low in my life 38
percent of americans i think i might
have seen you guys on the on your show
kaylee talk about this as well 30
percent of americans want to celebrate
uh they want to be patriotic and want to
celebrate the fourth of july something
is wrong and what i view that is a
distress signal with the country sending
out to leaders in every sphere politics
business media to your point greg those
everyone's a leader if you're a parent
you're a leader if you're a manager in
your company your own company or another
company you're a leader and everyone has
to accept some responsibility as we
think about these things and again
people can express themselves
the way they want we have a first
amendment and they should do that at the
end of the day
we all have to be better leaders if we
want the country to be better and more
perfect you know jesse the whole idea of
the hollywood elite
saying that they they hate america and
they don't respect america i mean part
of that i think is that 88 of the people
in this country think that the country
is headed in the wrong direction can
they separate the two no
you know how big on etiquette i am
judge i was raised properly and so i see
july 4th as a birthday party and you
don't go to someone's birthday party and
attack them you don't give them double
middle fingers as they're blowing out
the candles if you want to say something
say it on the way home all right but not
in front of their face like that i don't
even know who she is i see her always
saying liberal things i've never watched
anything she's been in is she even a
celebrity i don't even think she
qualifies she's rude and i think her
parents are disappointed in her i use
that line on my children this weekend
and i got to tell you that line works
being disappointed in someone is is very
effective and she knows how disappointed
i am in her
the other countries throughout the world
when they celebrate their independence
or their big days like we do do you
think they're trashing their own country
no do you think the french
on their big day or like running down
napoleon
or the mexicans are in the streets
saying oh we're run by cartels this
place stinks no they're being proud
mexicans or french people as proud as
you can be now biden says you know that
we're going backwards now i don't like
when democrats are constantly saying
we're moving backwards every time the
democrats change anything they consider
it progress but it's not progress the
democrats
to make an analogy would maybe put all
of the dining room chairs on the dining
room table and want to eat like that
well that's not progress
so
when the republicans know say we're
moving the chairs down to the floor
that's not going backwards that's just
making things normal
because people eat at a kitchen table
this abortion thing is really not
playing i saw a poll i think it was
monmouth it's like dead last yes you're
out of touch with this yeah and kaylee
wouldn't it make more sense for these
people who are so you know down on the
united states and the fourth of july and
the birth of this country wouldn't it
make sense for them to come out and say
you know what i'm gonna fight to pass a
law or do something to give them some
street cred as it relates to politics
yes no doubt about it i mean i woke up
on the 4th of july and my first thought
was i'm the most blessed person in the
world to live in the greatest country on
planet earth what kind of maniac wakes
up and says i'm not celebrating this day
i mean things have not gone my way in
this country i was born into a world of
roe v wade i hated it i thought it was
the greatest scourge of our nation and
for years have been committed to the
pro-life movement presidency of barack
obama presidency of the aging and
decrepit joe biden those didn't go my
way but it didn't make me less patriotic
so why have we gotten to a place in
society where people are like i hate
this country because i don't get my way
and i'm gonna kick and scream like a
four-year-old it's because the guy at
the top is setting the tone you don't go
to a birthday party to your point and
say
liberty's under assault freedoms are
reduced this is how i feel about the
country
wrap it up greg
i will wrap it up judge i'll do a little
rap please don't no
i don't think it's i don't think it's
about the celebrities as it is about
competition and i think um you know
right now we're living in this era of
identity politics which is based on
immutable traits right only a black
woman can understand a black woman only
a gay man can understand a a gay man
uh patriotism just blows that out of the
water it's about shared values it's not
about immutable traits it's about you
know we're americans you may be black i
may be white but we can agree that this
cheeseburger tastes awesome even though
we're from different backgrounds that's
what patriotism is and and that is
something that identity politics has
been fighting against uh since it i
guess it came out of the thing so that's
why it is so hated uh i would like to
see
i did this grift become more exposed and
that people can understand that like
we're patriot if you we've already
we've already marginalized religion and
now we're marginalizing patriotism so
what are you going to put in its place
if you put in its place identity
politics all that is is conflict it's
just people versus people i can't talk
to you you can't talk to me that's just
going to end in violence the whole point
of patriotism is for people who are
different to get to be part of the
melting pot that's all it is sounds
ideal but that's what it is but i think
that's the problem right now is like if
you look the woke
mentality finds this as the greatest
enemy it's ever faced patriotism yeah
they prefer tribalism i went to brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now